so we already know the historic border
crisis being felted across the country
and now the acting ice director sits
down in an exclusive interview with Fox
News touching on the battle to catch
criminal migrants who got away to the
lack of cooperation from American
Sanctuary cities Griff Jenkins did the
duties he's here to report now good
morning hey Bill good morning and you
know that border crisis doesn't end at
the border and no one knows that better
Bill than the men and women of eyes
tached with apprehending and removing
criminal migrants consider at this very
hour acting ice director Patrick leite
ner says they are aggressively pursuing
four of those suspects indicted for
beating the New York cops who were still
at large after Da Bragg released them
last week in New York's Sanctuary City
making the situation more dangerous by
not cooperating with the
feds the S Sanctuary jurisdictions are
inherently more unsafe because they're
letting these individuals out who have
you know very serious uh convictions at
times and are Public Safety threats if
not National Security threats it is a
concern and I'm very baffled by it and
with the unprecedented numbers illegally
crossing the border comes increased risk
to the interior just last week in
Maryland they nabbed an MS13 gang member
convicted of accessory to first degree
murder after authorities ignored an ice
detainer and released him and out in
Minnesota ice apprehended a Somalian
terrorist who run the country free for a
year until authorities matched him to
the FBI's Terror watch list agents
remarkably got him within 48 Hours of
being notified but when asked what keeps
him up at night Le Lightner says he's
worried about being able to get them all
just the increasing numbers of of
individuals who are on our dockets you
know so with the individuals that come
through it can only detain so many we
only have resources for x amount
there and Bill asked him about the
recent failed border Bill he says look
I'm just a lifelong cop I don't care
about the politics I just want Congress
to give us more resources in local and
federal law enforcement to work together
to keep Americans safe as for now we're
going to continue as is unfortunately
Griff thank you good reporting I'm Steve
duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis